good evening eastbourne
if any of you are here to see a
production of gangster granny you're in
the wrong theater so you might want to
leave now
this is the fourth hustings on our
national tour and it's good to be back
in sussex where i lived for many years
and where i was chairman of brighton
chemtown
thank you all for attending this evening
it is good to see so many friends from
brighton and colleagues
sitting here in the audience
these hustings are for us
the members of the conservative party to
take part in a great exercise of
democracy where we get to choose our
next leader
he or she will be announced on the 5th
of september and as with the party of
government then we'll become prime
minister very soon after
as ian dale who moderated many of these
hustings in 2019 said and i quote
i found sharing the hustings
a remarkably positive experience the
members really put the two candidates
through their paces and asked some very
searching questions
so i ask you tonight to make your
questions searching
to make them succinct
and to ask questions and not make
statements
one question each please so we get as
many questions from the audience as
possible
both of our candidates have a duty and
have expressed a desire to fulfill our
2019 manifesto
their differences will be about how to
achieve that in a very different world
from 2019
post-brexit
post-covered in uncertain times
internationally as we can see from the
ukraine and taiwan
and where our union as a nation is being
challenged so i'm sure that you want to
test our candidates to seek to establish
their strengths and to see who you think
is best capable of running our great
country
as we're all conservatives here tonight
i know that you'll be respectful of our
two candidates and keep your questions
positive
for them for me and for our cchq team
who've worked so diligently to set up
these hustings at short notice in
mid-summer these hustings run on a tight
schedule until we finish with a final
rally in london on the 31st of october
or even the 31st of august thankfully
it's not going on that long
as you know the ballot has opened and
many of you will have received your
ballot papers in the post and you can
vote online or by post
it's very easy to vote online or you can
choose traditional snail mail and if you
do post then please remember we're
trying to save money and to put a stamp
on the envelope
i hope tonight that you'll go away
enthused and energized in your
commitment to helping our party win the
next election
we need your help and support
finally there's a couple of people here
who i'd like to thank the first is katie
bourne our sussex police and crime
commissioner
we've known each other for about 10
years katie and i was very pleased to be
involved in your first campaign
and then the second person is john
belsey our regional chairman for the
south east
john you're doing a great job and it's
much appreciated
now ladies and gentlemen
let's get on with the show
please welcome jimmy mclaughlin
good evening eastbourne
it's great to be here by the beach on
such a sunny afternoon
i wanted to quickly introduce myself my
name is jimmy mclaughlin and i'm the
host of jimmy's jobs of the future
podcast i've worked at every level in
our party and in 2016 i joined the prime
minister as a special advisor in downing
street on business and entrepreneurship
i did that role for three years and left
in 2019 to start a family with my wife a
few months later the pandemic hits my
wife went back to work
and i became very much a stay-at-home
dad
it was a very different life to flying
around the world on raf voyager i had
very much gone from downing streets to
diapers
during this time we listened to lots of
podcasts and audio
not wanting to doom scroll at the time
and during that period i thought is
there something that i can do to help
tackle the unemployment crisis that was
going to be coming up
and so to that end i started jimmy's
jobs of the future interviewing
entrepreneurs about where they're
creating jobs and how they see the
future of our economy looking
because as conservatives we know
that a strong economy comes from private
enterprise and the risks that
entrepreneurs take
that's partly what we'll be interviewing
the candidates about
this evening about what their plans are
for a strong economy but this evening is
about you and listening to what you've
got to say i hope your ballot papers
have arrived today so without further
ado i'd like to welcome the various
camps to the stage thank you very much
please welcome member of parliament for
wielding nurse ghani
good evening everybody and welcome to
eastbourne it's good to be on home turf
in east sussex and to see
so many friendly faces
now many of you might have seen me on tv
i've been a bit busy with the 1922
committee
and as vice chair of the 1922 committee
i had to be neutral for the first part
of this election
now i no longer have to be neutral
and many of you have asked which
candidate i will back
only our party the conservative party
could have put together put forward two
stellar candidates research a wealth of
experience
vision and yes diversity
and the choice we have to make at this
election i know is momentous for our
country
and the future of our party
and i'm here to tell you i have chosen
and i have chosen to support
our brilliant foreign secretary
[Applause]
i could tell you that the reason i have
chosen to support liz trust is because i
have faith in her campaign and i do
litter's plan for our country is bold
just like her
and it's conservative
she will cut bills and stare us through
the energy and economic crisis
she will cut taxes that deprive
our families off their income and that
prevent your businesses from investing
to grow in our economy
she will defend the unity of our nation
and protect the peace in northern
ireland
i could tell you that i have chosen to
support liz trust whose record in
government is second to none who has
delivered dozens of post-brexit trade
drills who stood up against the tide of
identity politics
he stood up to russia
and was brave enough to stand up to
china
and many of you know that will be close
to my heart as an mp who's been
sanctioned both
by putin and the only female mp that's
been sanctioned by the chinese communist
party and president xi
now all of these are good reasons to
support liz truss
she doesn't know this but i'm actually
here to tell you something else
it's about her character
liz is straightforward when she tells
you is going to do something you can
trust her that it will get done
liz listens when colleagues come forward
with ideas or problems to solve she
engages with them she is inclusive
i've been a minister and now i'm a
backbencher and my experience with liz
trust is that she is both
fair
and honest
she reaches out and she unites the party
i hope that you agree with me that's
what makes a good leader
in these uncertain times and challenges
our party faces in government it is liz
that's going to bring us together
it's only by working together that we
can deliver change for the better
it's only by working together that we
can say truly hand on heart that the
best days of our country are ahead of us
and what matters to you all it is only
by working together that we can focus
and win the next general election
ladies and gentlemen it is my honor and
privilege to introduce my friend to you
liz truss
the united kingdom is a great country
and i know that a united conservative
party can unleash the potential of all
the people who make our country so great
to win the next election we need to
deliver deliver and deliver for the
british people
i know that our country's best days lie
ahead
i'm the candidate with a clear vision
for the future who can drive change and
get things done
as trade secretary i negotiated deals
with allies like australia and japan
creating opportunities around the world
for british business
and as prime minister i will continue to
deliver on the opportunities of brexit
i will lead a government committed to
core conservative principles
low taxes a firm grip on spending
driving great in the economy and giving
people the opportunity to achieve
anything they want to achieve regardless
of their background
i will work day and night to lead a
party in a government that puts more
money in your pocket and secures a
better life for you and your family
i've consistently delivered
when i have said i would
and i love our country
i want the best for us all and i'm the
person to deliver that
ladies and gentlemen please welcome liz
truss
[Applause]
hi everybody it's fantastic to be here
in eastbourne
i wasn't brought up in a traditional
conservative household
is the mic not working
oh sorry i think we've got a bike issue
can you hear me now
ah well done
i wasn't brought up in a traditional
conservative household
i was brought up in paisley in scotland
and in leeds where i went to a
comprehensive school
and what i saw at my school
is i saw children who were let down
they were let down by low expectations
because of the background they'd come
from
they were let down by
a poor and patchy quality of education
from leeds city council who are often
more interested in political correctness
than they were in making sure the kids
got english and maths right
and they're also let down by a lack of
opportunities
and that's what made me want to go into
politics because i hated to see that
waste of talent
and i want our country to be successful
i want everybody wherever they're from
whatever their background to have those
opportunities
and i want us to be an aspiration nation
but the reality is we're facing
difficult economic times
we have the backlash from covid
and we also have the war in ukraine
being perpetrated by vladimir putin
and we know
that we are facing some very very
difficult issues
we've had decades of low growth in this
country
so now my friends is not the time for
business as usual
we need to be bold
and we need to do things differently
and i would have a bold plan for
economic growth
first of all that means
unleashing those post-brexit
opportunities
changing our regulations getting all of
those eu laws off our statute books by
the end of 2023
including our laws on procurement and
investment so we're investing more in
the manufacturing parts of our country
i'd also reverse the increase in
national insurance
we shouldn't have put it up in the first
place it was a manifesto commitment not
to and we can still afford to pay for
health and social care out of general
taxation and afford to pay down the debt
starting in three years time
i'd also make sure we have a temporary
moratorium on the green levy
to cut people's fuel bills because we
know people are struggling to pay for
food and pay for fuel at the moment
i believe that as conservatives we need
to be on the side of people who work
hard and do the right thing
people who run businesses
people who are self-employed people who
go into work every day
those
those are the people whose side
we need to be on
i would also
oh
i would
[Music]
now
[Applause]
i think i think we have some
infiltrators
and i will wait until they uh are
evicted
[Applause]
we are the uk majority
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
good night can i just say
can i just say a few words on the
militant people who try and disrupt our
country and who try and disrupt our
democratic process and try and disrupt
our essential services
i would legislate immediately
to make sure that we are standing up to
militant trade unions
who stop ordinary commuters getting into
work
and i would legislate to protect
our essential services
and i will make sure
that militant activists
such as extinction rebellion are not
able
to disrupt ordinary people who work hard
and do the right thing and go into work
and i will never ever ever allow our
democracy to be disrupted by unfair
protests
now i know i know the vast majority of
people
in eastbourne
and around the south east
are hard-working people who want to do
the right thing and those are the people
we're on the side of and those are the
people that we will stand up for
we'll stand up for our farmers who do
such a fantastic job producing
great food
great crops
great wine in the vineyards around this
area
and i want to make sure our fields are
full of those great crops not full of
solar panels so i will focus on our
farmers producing food
rather than filling in forms
before i became a conservative mp
i was a counsellor
and i sat on a planning committee
and i'm afraid to say those are hours of
my life that i will never get back
because because the fact is my friends
that what happened
was that you thought you were making a
decision but you'd be overruled
by
bureaucrats in bristol
or by people in whitehall with top-down
planning targets
and what i would do is i would abolish
those targets
and i would do that in the leveling up
bill that is going through parliament at
the moment and instead
i would put in place low tax investment
zones
driven by local people that included not
just homes but also businesses and
infrastructure so local people could
have development where they thought it
was right
not where the bureaucrats thought it was
right
we also need to stand up
to vladimir putin
we know that if he is successful in
ukraine and we're doing all we can to
help the ukrainians that he won't stop
there
that he will want to roll back democracy
right across eastern europe he's been
very clear about his plans
that's why i'm proud that we were the
first european country
to send weapons to ukraine
and i as foreign secretary put the
toughest sanctions regime on russia of
any country in the world
but we can't be complacent about our
defense because we know that european
security has been threatened
so what i would do
is raise our defence spending to three
percent of gdp by the end of this decade
to make sure
we are able to afford proper security
and defence
and i will also deal with the people
traffickers making a misery of lives
with the small baits in the english
channel
i worked with priti patel on the rwanda
scheme
it is the right idea and we need to
extend it to more countries but we also
need to legislate in the british bill of
rights to make sure that we can't be
overruled by the echr because it's
vitally important that we protect our
own borders
and we also need to make sure
we also need to make sure that france is
held to account for its role in
protecting your borders
now
i spoke
i spoke to my french counterpart last
week to make it very clear that we
expect
french border guards to be working
all hours in dover to make sure that our
border is protected and i will continue
to make sure that that is the
case as well as protecting freedom and
democracy around the world and we have
an important role to do that
we also need to make sure it's protected
here in the uk and i think we've just
seen an example my friends of attempts
to disrupt a democratic process
but i'm a plain speaking yorkshire woman
i know that a woman is a woman
and we need to protect our single sex
spaces
our domestic violence shelters and you
know fantastic work is done by our pccs
on dealing with domestic violence
dealing with crime and we need to make
sure women and girls are protected
we also need to fight back
against the identity politics that has
infected our institutions i'm proud of
our country's history i'm proud of what
we've achieved i'm proud to go out into
the world as the uk foreign secretary
but we need more of that sense of pride
here in britain itself
our best days are ahead of us i don't
believe the narrative of decline i don't
believe the naysayers and i want us to
be proud to promote that
and i want us to be proud to be
conservatives because the people that
voted conservative in 2019
didn't vote conservative because they
wanted labour policies they voted
conservative because they believe and
share our values
whether that's about enterprise whether
it's about hard work whether it's about
supporting the family whether it's about
personal responsibility that's why
people voted conservative and those are
the people and those are the values we
need to stand up for
but we also need to deliver because we
made huge promises in 2019 about how we
were going to unleash opportunity across
the country
and i'm somebody that can deliver that
i shane in the department of trade where
i delivered dozens of trade deals even
though people said it wouldn't be
possible to do as well as the eu we've
delivered more deals than the eu in a
much shorter period of time
at the foreign office i've delivered the
northern ireland protocol bill to
resolve the issues that we have with the
protocol and restore the balance of the
belfast good friday agreement in
northern ireland
and i've stood up to vladimir putin
i've
worked with our counterparts across the
free world to make sure that ukraine
hasn't been sold out
and i will deliver
as prime minister i will make sure we
fulfill all of our promises in the 2019
manifesto and more and what's more i'll
take the fight to the opposition
to kierstarma yet another north london
labour leader who is completely out of
touch with what people in this country
want or the green party
who who talk who talk about being green
but let the rubbish pile up on the
streets of brighton
or the liberal democrats
or the liberal democrats
who are better at faking bar charts than
they are
they are delivering anything
and my friends we can work together we
can have all of the conservative party
on the pitch delivering for britain and
we can win the next general election
thank you very much thank you
so i just wanted to go through some of
the housekeeping rules for this evening
there's going to be no protesters please
further they've paid their 25 pound
conservative tax attacks that we can all
be in favor of
what i wanted to say is there are going
to be people with white hoodies walking
around they are going to be the people
that have the microphones that we are
going to be using for the questions when
we get to that page
and that will be really important so
make sure you flag them down and say
that you'd like to ask a question um so
without further ado i'd like to welcome
team rishi sunak to the stage
please welcome deputy prime minister
dominic raab
my friends welcome
i remember first meeting rishi sunak
when he first entered parliament back in
2015
imbued with the work ethic the business
experience and the family values
instilled in him by his parents
in particular when he worked in his
mum's pharmacy
doing the books
delivering prescriptions on his bike for
those elderly patients that couldn't
make it into the chemists
that enterprise outlook
nurtured by a career in business
backing firms with bright ideas that
just needed some investment so they
could scale up
rishi's story rishi's values
enterprise hard work family
they're our values
their conservative values
and almost immediately after the 2015
election of course we all face that very
difficult decision on which way to vote
and campaign in the eu referendum
and there is all sorts of pressure on
mps particularly new mps to back remain
but rishi has never taken the easy
option in his life
and he told me and i remember the
conversation very well
he said what's the point in working so
hard to get to the house of commons as
an mp
and then if you get there
you don't stand up for your convictions
well i remember
he didn't blink
he didn't hide
and he didn't just back leave and
campaign for it but he immediately
started thinking
about how to grasp the enormous
opportunities that brexit presents for
our great country
he wrote the seminal paper on free ports
back in 2016
he delivered the first ones as
chancellor in 2021
and that's rishi all over actions
not just words
now as chancellor in the biggest crisis
we've endured since the war
rishi put together a rescue package to
save jobs and businesses to get our
economy back on track
here in eastbourne alone rishi's rescue
package saved over 18 000 people their
jobs through the furlough
scheme thousands of businesses in
eastbourne benefited from 90 million
pounds in government-backed loans
19 000
self-employed got the support they
needed
and that's just here in eastbourne
when you needed him
rishi was there for you
and i know that as we face another
global challenge
the fight against inflation
that rishi is the candidate
with the credible plan to get inflation
down
to get investment up in those sectors
particularly important for your
businesses to thrive tourism digital
manufacturing and to cut taxes
but when it will help not hurt people
because the alternative choice in this
contest is unfunded tax cuts to the tune
of 50 billion pounds which will just put
more debt on our children's shoulders
that's not fair
that's not conservative
tax cuts that drive up inflation and
interest rates
that's not conservative either
just think about it for a moment
a tax cut of 400 pounds that cost you
seven thousand pounds on your mortgage
i think that's a pretty lousy deal and
it's a lousy deal
that would hand the keys of number 10
to kia stammer and the labour party
don't just take my word for it
on thursday nigel lawson margaret
thatcher's tax cutting chancellor warned
that those proposals would risk an
inflationary spiral that would cost us
the next election
which my friends brings me to my final
point
we all want to
win the next election
and the polling demonstrates that from
lib dem facing seats like my own like
eastbourne
right the way through to those northern
red wall seats we won at the last
election whether it's remain voters
leave voters north south town
country suburbs
rishi is the best place candidate to
beat kierstama and to win the next
election so that we avoid the disaster
of a labour government propped up by the
smp and the lib dems
my friends we can't let that happen
so let's make rishi our next prime
minister thank you very much
[Music]
my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work
patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
but also
an unshakable belief that we can build a
better future
here in east sussex and across the
nation the economy is going to be the
key challenge we need an exceptional
person to lead this country advances to
the huge challenges facing britain i
know he's someone who approaches tough
decisions with honesty and integrity
i've got complete confidence in him and
i'm supporting him for our leadership
[Music]
please welcome rishi sunak
good evening
good evening everyone thank you for the
warm welcome it's fantastic to be with
you here tonight in fact it's fantastic
to be out about across the country
talking to all of you all our members
great to be sharing ideas about the
future also great to be taking so many
selfies it turns out although honestly
i've never been happier when a member
asked me to take a selfie with one of
their children
finally someone at my own size to take
the photo in
but look i'm uh i'm standing here
tonight for one very simple reason and
that's because our country did something
completely extraordinary for my family
60 years ago when it welcomed them here
as immigrants and allowed them to build
a better life now i was raised with a
set of simple values that are core to
who i am
the first among those
is that family means everything to me
because the bonds of family are far
greater than anything
any government could ever hope to
replicate and we must never ever forget
that
in my family
we prioritized hard work
as the best way to forge ahead in life
my dad was an nhs gp my mum ran the
local chemist in southampton where i
grew up and i spent all my time working
in her shop out and about delivering
medicines and
doing her books her accounts her payroll
and saw the power of that small business
to provide jobs and opportunity in our
local community
now for my parents the best way that
they felt they could give a better
future to their three children
was simple
and it was through education
and i passionately believe today
that the best way that you reduce
inequality in society the best way that
you spread opportunity indeed the best
way that you transform lives is to
ensure that the birthright of every
child is a world-class education
so in a nutshell those are my values
patriotism family
service hard work aspiration and i know
looking at all of you here tonight that
those are probably your values too
and that's because they're conservative
values
and my story is an entirely conservative
story and that's why i want to be your
next prime minister to put those
conservative values into action to build
a better britain and just as our country
allowed my family to provide amazing
opportunities for me as prime minister i
want to do the same for everyone your
children and grandchildren to make sure
they have the same fantastic
opportunities too
but how are we going to do that
well we need to do three things
we need to restore trust
we need to rebuild the economy and we
need to reunite our country
now in order to restore trust we have to
start with honesty
and as you can see in this leadership
race i have not taken the easy path
because i believe our country does face
some significant challenges and i want
to be straight with everyone about those
and what is going to be required
to deal with them and even though it
doesn't make my life easy
i believe it is honest and that is what
leadership is about
but we also restore trust by delivering
on the things that we say the things
that matter to people
that's why i've set out a plan
to finally start reforming the nhs so we
can focus less on how much money we're
always putting in and more about the
efficient better healthcare that we're
getting out and getting the backlogs
down
it's why i want to restore trust with
our rural communities by supporting
farmers supporting food security and
protecting agricultural land for food
production and not solar panels
it's why
it's why i want to restore trust back
into the planning system to ensure that
local communities here and across the
country are the ones themselves that
decide where to build their homes how to
protect their green spaces and not be
told what to do by centrally imposed
targets from whitehall
[Applause]
and we restore trust also
by standing up for the things we believe
in and that means
i will be incredibly robust in standing
up against that lefty woke culture that
is trying to cancel our history our
values and indeed our women
and finally to restore trust we need to
tackle the issue of illegal migration
because for too long all of us have
watched on our tv screens scenes of
people coming here in boats and it's
simply unacceptable and it has to stop
with my bold plan under my leadership we
will finally get to grips with that
issue
stop people coming here illegally
control our borders and restore trust
back in the system
now when it comes to the economy i don't
need to tell any of you you know what
the number one challenge is we heard it
yesterday
it's inflation
inflation is the enemy that makes
everyone poorer and we've seen this
story before it reduces living standards
it erodes people's hard-earned savings
and pensions it pushes up mortgage rates
so of course i want to help people with
the cost of living just as i did over
the past two years that's why this
autumn will cut vat on energy bills but
what i'm not going to do
is pursue policies that risk making the
situation far worse and last far longer
especially
if what those policies amount to
is billion
borrowing billions and billions tens of
billions of pounds
in unfunded promises that we just put on
the country's credit card and then ask
our children and our grandchildren to
pick up the tab
now surely that isn't right
it's not responsible and it is certainly
not conservative
but i will cut taxes and i've set out a
plan to radically cut the basic rate of
income tax so that my conservative
government can always reward people's
hard work but we're going to do that
responsibly by being disciplined on
public services and public spending and
by growing the economy which is why this
autumn i want to radically reform our
business taxes to support and
incentivize those businesses that are
actually investing in the economy and
innovating more because that's how you
drive growth i want to be radical about
seizing the opportunities of brexit as i
did as chancellor to make sure that this
is the most dynamic economy in the world
for business
and i want to level up everywhere and as
you may have seen from a video clip
that's online i don't believe that's
just about our very large urban cities i
believe it's about investing and
leveling up in small towns in rural
communities in coastal communities like
those here in the south east
[Applause]
now when it comes to reuniting our
country in just a couple of years we
have to do
something very special we have to make
british political history
and that's winning a fifth election in a
row
now that has never been done before
but i am confident that working together
all of us we can do it
but it's going to mean that we have to
appeal to swing voters everywhere
here in the south east in the north in
the midlands
in liberal leaning areas in
labor-leaning areas in brexit supporting
areas in remain supporting areas in
wales and in scotland
and i passionately believe and all the
evidence
supports it that i am the candidate that
offers our party the best opportunity of
winning that election and ensuring kia
starmer never walks through the doors of
number 10 downing street
so in conclusion i'll just say this
you saw me as chancellor act radically
boldly ripping up the rule book
competently
to support millions of people's jobs and
businesses through a very difficult time
to make sure that our economy was
resilient through the storm
and as your prime minister i will bring
that same sense of urgency and grip and
competence and radicalism to every other
aspect of government to build a britain
where our children can walk safely on
the streets and our borders are secure
where we the nhs is always there for us
when we need it reformed and efficient
using the best technology well we've
made our schools the envy of the world
and we've created an economy that is
creating jobs and prosperity in every
part by harnessing the future
innovations that we will create that's
the better britain that i will build
but more than that i promise you this
i will give you my everything my heart
my soul
to ensure that each and every one of you
here this evening
will always feel
enormously proud
of the conservative government that i
will be privileged to lead so i humbly
ask for your support not just to be
your next party leader
but also
the next prime minister
of our great country thank you
i just wanted to quickly ask
how
many people are more than 90 decided
which way they're going to vote not
asking which way but raise your hands if
you
have decided and if you've got a t-shirt
on and you don't put your hand up i'm
going to dub you into the campaigns
all right so about 25 or so then
interesting
interesting and how many of you have
received the ballot papers
oh yes
cchq are going to be tough with that
that's a good that's a
that's a very good amount there
and they told us that all the leadership
contests were going to be the same and
then we get all the protesters in like
that
very relieved it didn't happen when i
was on stage that's got to be the
main thing i was concerned about what we
were going to have to do with that at
that point
all right without further ado please
welcome liz trust to the stage
[Applause]
so first question that i wanted to ask
is that there's a generation that are
sort of 35 and under that have
effectively only ever known a sort of
permanent sense of crisis almost whether
it be the financial crash brexit covid
and now the news from the bank of
england yesterday about possibly one of
the longest recessions we've ever seen
and the tightest squeeze on living
standards
what's your pitch going to be to win a
fifth term
well
the generation of people who have
you know grown up recently the
under 30s first of all i think that they
are natural conservatives they're more
likely to have started up their own
business than older generations they're
more likely to have a side hustle in
whatever work they do they're doing
things alongside it i think we've seen a
real generation of self-starters who've
had to cope with the difficulties of
covid i've got two daughters aged 13 and
16. i know it's been tough for them
being out of school but i do think it's
also created a certain kind of
resilience so i think we've got an
incredibly talented generation coming
through and i think what we have to show
as conservatives is we're on their site
so one thing i would do is make sure
people who rent are able to use their
rental history to get a mortgage so it's
easier for young people to get on the
housing ladder i want to be able to hold
universities to account better to make
sure that they are providing
face-to-face tuition
as well
and
and also
i want to look at some of the
levels of interest in the student loan
system to make sure that those students
and ex-students are getting a fair deal
but fundamentally what we need to do is
we need to show
people that there is hope and there is
an optimistic future ahead of us and as
i said we're brilliant at startups but
we need to be better at funding the
scale-ups so one of the things i would
do is unleash more investment into our
economy through reforming solvency too i
met some investors in the city this
morning they told me that if we get on
and do that we could release tens of
billions i mean we can create
the british version of silicon valley
you know we can create real
opportunities we have a talented
generation of young people ready to take
those opportunities on but we need to
get the growth and we need to you know i
know there are difficult forecasts out
there but forecasts are not destiny and
what we shouldn't be doing is talking
ourselves into a recession we should be
keeping we should be
keeping taxes low
you know doing all of those things we
can now do differently because we've
left the eu and really show
show young people in particular the huge
benefits of being a conservative and
let's pick up on something specific
there in terms of when it comes to the
energy bills because that is something
that is that is rising and by the start
of next year you're up to the point
where an average household could almost
be spending 20 percent of their monthly
income on energy
but they're people protected by the cap
to an extent businesses aren't and if
you're going to be in creating a product
this winter as a business it's going to
be really tough what can we do to help
those people well first of all reversing
the national insurance rates will help
business and that's important keeping
corporation tax low will help business
and help keep us competitive that's also
important but what i want to do is have
more incentives for the oil and gas
companies to use resources in the north
sea to exploit more gas i want us to
frack in parts of the country that where
there's local support so that we can get
so that we can get the energy security
we need and also what i want to see is
fast forwarding of things like small
modular nuclear reactors nuclear
projects we need to be quicker at
building projects that is another thing
that's too slow at the moment and i
would legislate to reform some of the
rules that allow us to move forward on
those things earlier i just want to say
one more thing about young people i mean
people may know about me that i have a
bit of a dubious past and that when i
was a teenager i was a member of the
liberal democrats but i i i'm sorry
sorry um you know we all made mistakes
we all made mistakes we all had teenage
misadventures and that was mine
some people yeah some people have you
know sex drugs and rock and roll i was
in the liberal democrats i'm sorry
i'm sorry but
but i became a conservative because i
met people who were like-minded and i
thought i believe in what they're
talking about you know it was for me it
was about
personal freedom the ability to shape
your own life and shape your own destiny
and that's what motivated me to become a
conservative so i think talking about
our ideas is really important and
talking to other people and reaching out
from the party i think sometimes the
conservative party is very very good at
raising money
and we should make the same kind of
effort that we make raising money
reaching out to new people and
convincing them about our ideas because
that's what motivated me to switch
at that age and what was the moment that
you decided to sort of step in to the
arena as it were because we've got a
thousand members here this evening many
will have served as local councillors
and thought about filling out that kind
of parliamentary candidates for what was
the moment i thought i'm gonna i'm gonna
do this
well i was sort of i i was active in
local association i became chairman of
the association to be honest because
nobody else wanted to do the job uh so
obviously it was a very highly highly it
was quite a small association london i
became chairman no one else wanted to do
a job and then
you know i became a
counsellor
and at the same time i
i was just really interested in i was
working in
the oil and gas industry at the time it
was an interesting job but i thought
politics was something more politics
could help shape our country's future
and i think that's what made me sign up
to get on the candidates list and what
is the
the governor of the bank of england
today talked about people that have left
the workforce and actually this being
one of the biggest domestic pressures
that we've got on inflation aside from
russia and so on
what will you do to encourage those
people back to the workforce what can we
do about that well
the governor is right the reason we have
an inflation problem is it's a supply
side problem there is not enough supply
in our economy that is why
things like reducing national insurance
will help contribute to fulfilling those
supply needs so it's not inflationary
it's actually going to help deal with
inflationary pressures likewise keeping
corporation tax low will help new
investment and help develop supply in
the economy
on the point about
people you're absolutely right there are
five million people in britain who are
economically inactive i think we used to
call that being unemployed but we now
call that economically inactive what i
would do is look at the incentives in
the benefit system but also make sure
that we are providing opportunity or
rather the private sector is providing
opportunities so when i talk about
investment zones that is about using a
conservative way
low taxes to attract businesses to an
area at the same time let's get people
who are
currently not in the workforce encourage
those people to apply for those jobs so
it's a combination of
incentives within the benefits system as
well as actively providing people with
the skills and training they need to do
those jobs but it is a massive challenge
for our country i know there are a
shortage of skills in hospitality in
social care in farming and we really do
need to work to get more people back
into the workplace after covert you only
need to go down eastbourne uh beach and
see the amount is that where you've been
jimmy it is indeed
[Laughter]
don't tell me otherwise if you were 22
in 2022 what sector do you think you'd
be looking at because there's so much
innovation happening out there as you
say
where do you think you'd be looking to
go
no i think there are all kinds of
exciting exciting industries i talked
earlier about the local wine industry
here which is booming i mean the the
fields are full of vineyards which is
fantastic to see and i do i do like wine
i think i'd be good sector
to be part of i think the tech industry
is fantastic in britain but what we're
brilliant at is the startups
and then there isn't enough funding
coming through so this is why i want to
unlock that investment in the city into
tech startups right across the country
and also make sure we've all got the
super fast broadband we need
to actually be able to run those types
of businesses what more can we do to
support fast-growing startups the
scale-up sector because we aren't as
good as that we are very good at
starting businesses but we're not as
good as that growth side what can we do
on that side
so i this morning i met a group of
funds
talking about exactly how do we unlock
investment and it is things like
changing the solvency to rules which are
very very risk-averse on how much
how much capital is allowed to be
released changing those rules would
unlock huge levels of investment which
could go into helping britain have a
much
faster growing tech sector a much faster
growing sort of scale-up sector so as
you say we're very good at the small
businesses but we need the next
generation of microsofts and googles to
be in britain not just to be in the
united states and that's that's why i
think it's so important to take
advantage of these post-brexit freedoms
and how can we get more share ownership
is at its lowest level since the 1980s
in terms of people holding these
companies and having a stake in our
future how can we improve that
well i think that that's a very good
point i think
one of the things we have been doing is
working to
make it easier to ipo in this country to
float your company uh in this in this
country i think we as conservatives
should be talking about share ownership
and property ownership more sometimes i
think we've been a bit afraid to talk
about conservative principles but we
value a society where people have shares
where they own property where they own a
stake in the future and i think that is
partly a communication problem but it's
also about making life easier for retail
investors
using technology better i think it's
important as well interesting we're
going to come to audience questions in
just a moment so get ready to approach
the people with the mics but just before
we do that i wanted to ask you what your
favorite podcast was aside from jimmy's
jobs of course jimmy's jobs is obviously
my favorite podcast i do actually like a
podcast which is called women with balls
and i don't know if people it's by katie
balls of the spectator it's not any um
any reference to uh male genitalia or
anything like that and um yes i do think
that's very good because it has a lot of
punchy women on it very important as
well right so we're going to go to
questions on that let's go down first
here
so
yeah we're just just right i might just
stand up yeah yeah i have literally gone
for the person right behind you so that
with a liz banner so
could you hold it for me please frank
hi i'm tara moore i'm 37 and i'm
significantly impaired i'm also the
brexit campaign manager
considering there's a load there there
are many of the population with a
invisible disability or significant
impairment do you know what personal
independence
payments are and how will your
government ensure that we get
meaningful employment
well
thank you
first of all
i think what you are advocating for is
incredibly important to be honest i
don't know the level of personal
independence payment but what i can say
to you
is that what i want is to make it much
easier for people in your position to
get into jobs and also have the
opportunity to set up your own
businesses and i know that the
department of work and pensions
is working on how we do this better and
how we help you you're shaking your head
you're obviously not happy uh with the
department of work and pensions and what
i'd want to do is talk to you
about how can we help
uh help deal with the issues that you
face in getting employment how can we
make it
better
in terms of the available opportunities
including be able to start up your own
business and i would want to do that as
prime minister because my focus is
unlocking the talent and potential of
every single person in this country and
that includes your talent and potential
[Applause]
thank you very much good evening um i've
got an eye for the next general election
the red wall voters were very very
important to us at the last election
what do you think you can do to retain
the most of those votes going again to
the conservatives
well you're right about the
red wall voters they were incredibly
important and as somebody who comes from
the north of england i found it
incredibly heartening that many people
you know in places like west yorkshire
uh in places like
you know county durham voted
conservative for the first time and the
reason they voted conservatives they
were fed up of years and years of labor
letting their area down and they didn't
want to be patronized they didn't want
handouts they didn't necessarily want
more government spending what they want
is opportunities jobs and enterprise and
that's why it's so important that we
help industries like the steel industry
become more competitive internationally
it's why it's important that we get the
investment into our manufacturing
industries by reforming things like
solvency too and it's also important
that we deliver what we said we would
deliver in 2019 we promise new hospitals
we promise new railway lines we promise
new roads we promise fiber
you're right it does cost money but
there is money in the budget for it but
sometimes i'm afraid there's too much
government bureaucracy in the way of
getting it done and what i can say to
you
is i am somebody who doesn't take no for
an answer from whitehall i push things
through uh regardless of some of the
protests and what i would make sure
is that if elected as your prime
minister this autumn i will put those
projects on fast track so we're
delivering for people and so by 2024
we have spades in the ground
in the red wall seats and in seats
across england where we've made promises
including here in eastbourne where i
know we're promising a hospital you know
i will make sure those things happen
because people will
see whether or not we deliver and that's
what's important
[Applause]
somebody obviously has a mic at the back
who shouldn't have one
sorry for the interruption everybody
could i just say jimmy that i take it as
a compliment that i'm so popular with
extinction rebellion
anyway
you touched upon
getting people back to work
from my perspective from the
introduction of the new health and care
bill
um and with it now being introduced
especially with the introduction of you
know palliative care and end-of-life
care
um it's a very specialist field um and
having spoken to a lot of people um
how do you intend to not only
cover the chasm that there is within the
uh within the care sector of specialist
people but how do you intend to retain
them
that seems to be one of the biggest
issues we've got is not actually
employing people or getting people into
those jobs but it's actually retaining
them
so
as i said earlier on
i would make sure
that the money
that we have allocated to health and
social care
goes to social care because i do think
that's where some of the biggest issues
are
and what we have at the moment is people
in nhs hospital beds because there isn't
enough space in social care so by giving
the money to local councils to fund
social care we'll also be freeing up
space in the national health service but
you are right
you are right about the motivation of
frontline people in the health service
and in social care and partly it's about
funding i understand that i know their
issue about mileage rates for people in
social care i know there are issues
about wages
and we can help with the national
insurance reverse for example on things
like wages but it is also about the
respect people are treated with it's
about the level of centralized
bureaucracy that we particularly
experience in the nhs so it's also about
treating people with respect and making
sure people are empowered on the front
line to do their jobs so the jobs are as
fulfilling as possible i think that's
very very important and how can we make
sure that the nhs is able to keep pace
with the private sector in terms of the
different array of flexibility they're
now able to offer in terms of working
from home etc people like teachers and
nurses and doctors aren't going to have
that flexibility and actually early on
in their careers they're sort of sent to
all parts of the country with very
little control what can the government
do to kind of enforce a bit of more
flexibility in that well i have to say
there's quite a lot of the private
sector who want more of their staff to
be in the office as well so i don't
think it's just the public sector i do
think it is important that we get more
people back into offices
because we need to make sure our town
centres and city centres thrive but also
you learn from other people when you're
in work when you're talking to each
other and i think whilst it worked to
some extent during covet i certainly got
zoom fatigue i know a lot of people in
the civil service got zoom fatigue so i
think we do need to try and encourage
people to come into the office you know
more than they do at present i think
there is a case for more flexibility in
terms of where people are
allocated to within the national health
service for example and i think there's
a lot there's a big case for more local
control
at the moment what i hear is people are
frustrated by the level of central
dictat they're frustrated by the number
of levels of management above them and i
think by having more local control
you help empower people you make jobs
more fulfilling and rewarding and you
also get things done better because the
people locally know much better than the
people in whitehall about what's going
on and how to fix the problems
liz um
vladimir putin must have been over the
moon when boris fell and certainly the
ukrainians were very unhappy about it
what will you do to make putin feel a
little less smug and put heart into the
gallant ukrainians
well you know you were right that boris
johnson is hugely respected in ukraine
you know there's both a street and a
croissant named after him and i don't
think many i don't think many
international leaders have achieved that
and it is because of the leadership
we've shown
in ukraine
not just in
supporting the ukrainians but also
standing up to russia and calling out
putin calling out lavrov calling out the
appalling aggression
that has characterized
russia over the last over the last 10 to
15 years and
i know
having dealt directly with russia
that they are concerned about the stance
that we've taken that they can see the
leadership we've shown and i can assure
you i will continue to do that i will
con continue to stand up to putin stand
up to lavrov but also put them put our
money where our mouth is and it's
important that it's not just about
rhetoric that it's also hard security
the uk is investing in that's why i
intend to increase defense spending to
three percent of gdp and also re review
our integrated review to make sure it's
dealing with the threat that we now face
on european shores which is much worse
than it was five or ten years ago
[Applause]
thank you for all you've said so far uh
i'm in the hospitality sector and i want
i i was listening to you say that you
want to get some of that five million
people back into work i would like you
to help me
deal with the following cases i was
trying to employ people
to help in my business and on five
occasions i had people accepting jobs
and then were told that their part-time
jobs they can't afford to take them
because they would lose their benefits
more than i was able to pay yes
thank you well
you you make absolutely the right point
and this is my point about making the
incentives in the benefit system work so
people
are better off when they take up jobs
and we made some changes
because of covert covert is now over
we now need to change the benefit system
back and we also need to more actively
be encouraging people into work because
it's not just damaging your business
the ability to get people to work in it
it's also costing taxpayers money as
well so it's a win-win to change the
system to help those people back into
work and i'm determined to do that
[Applause]
hi liz
i'm a teacher i'm also a mum of a 13 and
a 16 year old
can you tell us a little bit about what
you would do to help children recover
from lost learning after covid
well
during kovid we developed a large number
of tutors across the country and what i
would want to use is use those tutors to
help children catch up i would also want
to make sure we're dealing with the
mental health issues resulting from
covert i know how hard it was for young
people to be isolated during that time
when they should have been with their
friends they should have been at school
so what i would want is more mental
health support in our schools to help
teachers out as well i think that's very
important i also want to support schools
to offer more wrap-around care for
children i think that's really important
for working parents and it also helps
children you know get more of that
social exposure which is so important to
their development but
i know from having a 13 and six year old
daughter it is a
it's an exciting age but it's also a
challenging age and i think one of the
big problems parents face
is mobile phones and social media and
kids contacting each other and winding
each other up on whatsapp
is one of my my uh
my concerns i can tell you about
teenagers sounds like tory mp's what's
up group sometimes but it's not as bad
as that
i'm not sure teenage girls were as bad
as tori and pete so i think that's uh
that's being a bit strong gentleman here
mike staples chair of the conservative
policy forum in lewes and letter writer
for telegraph
[Laughter]
with with hindsight
the mathematical modeling that led to
lockdown may have caused more harm than
good we just heard some reference to it
before restricting
our right to heat our homes and drive
our cars will you critically examine the
scientific group think
for
net zero
well
although although i am a fan of
mathematics and in fact one of the
things i did as education minister was
create the new big math gcse that my
daughter has just sat which she's not
particularly happy about because she was
saying mum why did i have to sit all
those extra papers and it was basically
down to me
when i was education minister i do think
sometimes
we use mathematical models where they're
not appropriate
and
you know the housing algorithm
is a similar case
where
it's a human decision
whether or not to build houses in a
local community
it shouldn't be down to an algorithm so
i think we've always got to be very
careful
to intermediate with our own thinking
about what is right for our society
having been through the lockdowns
and seeing the experiences of other
countries i do think we went too far and
i would not want to have another
lockdown and no lockdown would happen
under my leadership i can assure you of
that
but
but on the subject
of this on the subject of net zero we do
need to transition to net zero but i
want to do so in a way that doesn't
clobber households and doesn't clubber
businesses that's why i'd have immediate
moratorium on the green energy levy
while we look at better ways of
delivering net zero that are using
private sector innovation and technology
to deliver and
at the meeting i had in the city this
morning you know there are tens of
billions of pounds chasing that green
investment
that is what we should be doing we
should be looking at how we get that
green investment into our economy at the
same time as using gas as a transition
fuel because i think that's going to be
incredibly important in the run-up to
this winter where vladimir putin is
going to try and play games with the
european with european gas supply is
that we are using our own resources in
the north
[Applause]
thank
sea
um
so you talk about the needs to um
implement new laws to stop annoying
protests being a student of sussex
university i can very much empathize
with that
uh we got a great display of it earlier
today some of your friends probably
um
so
i'm just concerned about how that's
going to be done whilst balancing the
crucial right to freedom of speech and
freedom of expression
so i completely agree with freedom of
speech and freedom of expression what i
think is wrong
is when extinction rebellion activists
glue themselves to trains and disrupt
commuters who are going about their
business
and likewise
you know i am fine with peaceful
protests but you know the the situation
we had in parliament square
with a whole bunch of people camped in
tents for week on weeks on end is not
the same as peaceful protest so to me
you know i'm a believer in
freedom to do
as you want
provided you don't harm others that's
the that's the fundamental concept for
me
but what i think we've got to a stage of
in our society
is where there is deliberately
disruptive activity which isn't just
about peaceful protest it's about trying
to disrupt you know democracy trying to
disrupt people's everyday lives and i
think that is a problem so there's a
there's a balance to be struck but
one person's freedom should not mean
that other people suffer misery
liz
i had two quick final questions there's
been a lot of blue on blue in this um
leadership election as there inevitably
is going to be but i wanted to know what
do you think is your opponent's greatest
so rishi is somebody i've worked with in
cabinet
he's a very intelligent person he's a
very
competent minister and i would be very
pleased that if i'm successful in this
contest if he would work work with me in
our team
and the final one
and it's a very specific one and
personal to me you also have in con
common with him the fact that you are
a parent to two daughters and as we have
recently welcomed our second daughter
into the world i wondered if you got any
advice on bringing up daughters in the
21st century
so my number one piece of advice is
delay as long as possible them getting a
smartphone that is that is genuine
advice to every parent because the
minute they get their hands on it it's
an absolute nightmare you know i i had
to introduce this idea of a locked box
to put their phone in which was an old
petty cash box because it was just being
completely abused so i think that's my
number one piece of advice is keep them
off the mobile phones as long as
possible and try and work with other
parents in a club to uh stop them using
peer pressure to to get onto phones and
social media brilliant thank you so much
[Applause]
my wife is certainly going to be chuffed
with that answer in terms of adding that
to the list of that
and without too much further ado i
wanted to welcome mr sunak to the stage
[Applause]
so
18 months time
you're about to go to the country and
call a general election and you are
going off the back of
the toughest economic squeeze that
people have ever felt in their pockets
and the longest recession that we may
well have ever seen according to the
bank of england what's going to be your
pitch to the country to win a record
fifth term
well the first thing
we need to do in order to make sure we
can win that election is have got
through this inflation problem by then
right and that's why i'm particularly
worried about policies that risk making
it worse and last longer because if this
is a problem that isn't just for this
winter it's a problem for next winter as
well and beyond because as the bank of
england said they're worried about
inflation becoming embedded
then there's no hope that we're going to
win that next election absolutely none
right it's as simple as that we all
heard what they said yesterday all of
you saw the numbers
and if we don't get a grip of this thing
and get a grip of it fast then we can
kiss goodbye to winning that next
election so the first thing to put
ourselves in a position to win is to get
through inflation and get through it
quickly and not do things worse but then
thank you right but then yeah i
right
so we'll get that done under my
leadership you know i've got a plan
we're going to grip it we're going to
get through it we'll help people in the
short term but that's not enough right
we've got to build
a vision of the britain that we want to
see we want to see our kids grow up and
i talked a little bit about in my speech
it's delivering on the things that we
talked about it's finally reforming the
nhs so that people are not waiting a
year for treatment that they need and
deserve because we've got to grips with
it we've found the efficiency there it's
making sure that our schools are the
envy of the world because that's how
we're going to provide a better future
for our kids is making sure that we get
tough on crime so that our women and
girls can walk around the streets safely
and it's about building an economy that
in every part of the country is creating
jobs and opportunity and prosperity for
people and if they feel that that's all
happening
that we delivered on the things that we
said that we're building that better
britain then they're absolutely going to
come and re-elect us but it is going to
mean we have to appeal to people
everywhere and i said earlier i'm the
person that can appeal to those swing
voters and ensure that we beat
kierstarma at that general election
and with all the challenges that are
going to be faced this winter as we were
talking about those companies that
produce products aren't going to be
protected by the energy cap and are
going to be facing huge builds what
specifically are you going to be able to
do for those high intensive businesses
yeah well the most important thing that
we need to do this winter is is help
people is help families particularly the
most vulnerable families through what is
going to be a very difficult period
right and some of the proposals that
you've heard elsewhere are not going to
do that quite frankly and that's why as
chancellor i announced support that was
particularly targeted at the most
vulnerable and any compassionate
conservative government i'm sure
everyone in this room would want to make
sure that those in our society who are
going to just struggle too much with
bills that are going up a thousand
pounds 1500 pounds get the help they
need that's got to be the priority
that's what i did as chancellor that's
what i'll do as prime minister
now in terms of getting businesses to
grow the things we need to do are
focused on what's going to achieve that
right now we've had this debate on
corporation tax
right i don't want to stick with the
failed policies of the past right that's
what some people are suggesting hasn't
worked if we want businesses to actually
invest in the economy to expand their
factories to put more lines in to
produce more things that's how we create
more jobs that's how we'll get inflation
down if companies are producing more we
need to cut the taxes on those things
focusing on corporation tax hasn't
achieved that investment in this economy
today no better than it was a decade ago
in spite of us doing all those things on
corporation tax because it's not the
right tax to focus on and that's where
my experience in business my time as
chancellor my conversations with
business
have led me to the conclusion we need to
be much more radical we need to reform
business taxes to cut them on the things
that make a difference and that's
business investment business innovation
if we get those tax cuts in place then
we can help those businesses expand grow
create jobs and prosperity and crucially
help get inflation down because as i
said before if we don't do that we're
all in real trouble and on that there is
a challenge that's happened that the
bank were talking about this morning the
fact that lots of people have not
returned to the
workforce you know half a million
perhaps even more some of it's long
covered and then there's lots of other
reasons as well that are being
attributed to it how do we actually
persuade them back to the workforce yeah
well you know the answer is is not
canceling the nhs and social care levy
because actually as people people know
or cutting ni more generally if you're
over the
state pension age and many of the people
who have left the workforce or those
older people you don't pay any national
insurance anyway
right so that's not going to help if
that's the reason that you think they
left so what we do need to do is make
sure that we have
the right kind of workforce or the white
kind of working conditions
for those people to be attracted back
and actually as chancellor i spent some
time talking to lots of them and we
started to figure out how can we do this
because you're absolutely right we're
short of about half a million workers
disproportionately elderly now what they
say is it's far less about the money
it's much more about the flexibility of
how they work because they want to work
but they want to work part-time half the
week a couple of days three days and we
need companies to actually adjust the
jobs that they're offering in order to
entice these people back into the
workforce now they also because they
only work part-time they don't earn huge
amounts and because we've raised the
threshold
last month that's what i did at which
you can earn money without paying a
penny of national insurance actually
they're not paying very much tax these
people because they're not earning a
huge amount and we've taken them out of
paying any tax so focusing purely on
taxes the answer is just wrong right
because that's not the issue here these
people are making a lifestyle decision
and they can't find the jobs that suit
their new lifestyle and that's the thing
that we're going to need to crack and
the government can't do that alone we
need to work with industry and private
sector to create much more flexible jobs
for them and for those that want to pick
up a new skill that doesn't take very
long that can take a few weeks we need
to make sure we have those kind of
opportunities for them to do that fast
as chancellor and a minister beforehand
you're taking dozens of and dozens of
decisions every day
what is one that you would look back on
and approach differently now
well i'm sure there's many right
you know when you're making policy in
the crisis when you've only got hours
and days to get things right it's i mean
it's almost impossible to get everything
right and we didn't have a playbook
right when i was when i became
chancellor three weeks later i was doing
a budget a week after that coronavirus
hit and there was no playbook there was
no manual sitting there in the treasury
that said okay this is what you do when
you have to shut an entire country down
i was having to come up with these
things fast and then make sure that they
actually worked and i'm proud of my
record in doing that and i think by and
large you know we protected over 10
million jobs protected businesses people
were forecasting unemployment would
spiral into the millions 14
but because of the things i put in place
it didn't and i'm going to bring that
same degree of radicalism and confidence
to all the other aspects of government
but the things that look we clearly
struggled to get right at the beginning
we're getting cash out to companies
and we have to set up lots of different
ways to get loans many of you in this
audience may have benefited from them
and we started with one loan program
with the banks but it just wasn't quick
enough and companies were saying if we
don't get cash now we're out of business
by the end of the week so we had to
create a new loan program the bounce
back loan program that did solve that
problem but you know we had to come back
to that to get that right and actually
the last thing was the the thing that
you just talked about was
earlier on i would like to have started
focusing on this issue of people leaving
the workforce
and figure out if there are things we
could do to have stopped them leaving in
the first place it's actually hard to
attract people back and actually if we'd
known that this was happening maybe with
things we could have done quicker up
from
okay and britain is one of the best
places in the world to start a business
but something that we're not as good at
is scaling businesses and it's a problem
now that is becoming ever more apparent
in terms of people
the cultural side of people not wanting
to grow and scale as much as happens in
the u.s for example what would you do to
change that yeah
well i don't think the answer is
actually
lots more money and financing right and
people will say oh these scale-up
businesses they leave lots of capital
and we should you know we can reform
lots of financial markets to do that we
can do that and we should do that and i
started that work as chancellor because
as you know this is an area i know very
well this is my background
professionally if you talk to anyone at
any of those businesses
what will they say they'll say the
number one thing they need is people
right if you talk to any entrepreneur in
the uk
growing a company and you know this from
your experience what do they all say
what's the limiting factor in their
growth it's getting amazing talent right
so that means you've got to focus on
that side of the equation you've got to
make sure that we're training young
people we're giving them all the routes
that they need not just university but
apprenticeships too other short courses
because it's not just about degrees and
we've got to have a visa system that
attracts the best and the brightest from
all around the world because if you look
at
those companies that you're talking
about over half of them
have a founder
that wasn't actually born here in the uk
if you look at all our stem researchers
across all our uk universities around
half of them also
not born here in the uk
so yes i want to clamp down on illegal
migration yes i want to control our
borders but if we're going to grow our
economy we need to be a beacon of talent
for the best and the brightest anywhere
in the world and that's why as
chancellor thank you
there you are what was the moment that
you decided that you wanted to become a
parliamentary candidate what was the
time from becoming a member of the
conservative party to actually becoming
a thinking i want to step into the arena
and i want to do something what was that
moment yeah it was inspired by my
parents that you heard me talk about and
they're obviously not political but
they worked in primary health care my
dad was a gp my mum was a chemist that's
the world i grew up in
and everywhere i would go in southampton
when i was out delivering medicines all
people would just stop us at the
weekends
you know they'd see me and they'd say oh
you're dr sunak's son you'll mrs sunak's
son
and then they would proceed to tell me
something about what my parents had done
for them their parents grandparents kids
and that always stayed with me i found
that incredibly inspiring that they as
individuals
well because well that's not my not my
strong point and you're probably all the
better off for it as well
but you know i found that inspiring that
they as individuals could have such an
impact on our community
and that's why i wanted to be a member
of parliament and i want to have that
same impact on the community that i'm
privileged to represent in my new home
in north yorkshire and i think all the
mps here and those who are counsellors
will feel exactly that same thing it's
an incredibly rewarding thing to be able
to make a difference to the people who
are your responsibility to represent and
that was my driving force for it so i
had it you know growing up and then you
know at some point i wanted to act on it
but you know i do believe you're better
off in politics if you've had actually a
real career in something in my career
was in business first to bring that
experience to parliament but it was that
it was inspired by my parents and how
they served our community and if you
were 22 in 22 what career do you think
you'd be going into because in the early
noughties it was very much banking was
the kind of like what people ambitious
people wanted to go into what do you
think it'd be now
yeah i think one one thing that's
crystal clear and again i'm biased
because it's my own background and
experience but you know young people are
much more interested in entrepreneurial
careers now right and they're much more
interested in working for new companies
not necessarily all the big companies
and they're much more interested in
changing jobs more frequently and i
think that's something that we should
celebrate and support look for me if it
was me you know i definitely want to do
something that was doing something
different doing something new creating a
new product a new service that we don't
have today that's all going to improve
our lives and transform the world in
which we live that's the kind of culture
that i experienced when i was living in
california and i think it's incredibly
inspiring and empowering so look if i
was a young person i'd want to go and do
something like that and you can do that
in every industry it's not just when you
think about it's not just pure
technology actually i met an amazing
business recently and they're doing
agritech right and we know we all want
to improve our food security in this
country we want to grow more fruit grow
more vegetables here that's good for us
good for inflation and there are amazing
british companies that are using
cutting-edge techniques to do all of
that here actually and that would be
great for the economy and that's just an
example of using technology in a way
that's going to solve a big problem for
us now that would be something exciting
to do absolutely right and now we're
going to take some audience questions
and arms go straight up in this we'll go
to the gentleman over there someone here
right yeah yeah live
oh yeah we're just we're just waiting
for the mic if you just go across there
i've been really awkward there
i used to do the mics and david cameron
used to make me run from side to side of
this joke i'm sure he did rishi whoever
whoever gets the top job
is facing a problem as big as the covid
problem
i think one of the good things that came
out of covid was the daily tv reports
with the different experts in there
giving the country data so the country
could come with you
can you if you get the top job
or half the audience will say when you
get the top job um
can can you can you commit to giving the
country data the too many things you
can't get to a gp you can't sign up you
can't go to the dentist my son wants a
driving license he can't get a driving
test
there's all these basic basic things
which aren't working
can you publish some data
and then come back each week
and tell the country what you've done to
improve those things i think that would
win you the next and us the next
election
wow
you make an excellent point look i
remember those press conferences vividly
because i had to do so many of them
right and uh in fact that's probably
where you all first saw me right i mean
i i got you know suddenly there i was at
this press conference next to the prime
minister and all of you like who is this
guy right and uh this pandemic was about
to hit and i had to stand up and do
these things and i did you know what i
like you so many people say to me that
they got enormous reassurance from those
press conferences and they liked being
spoken to like adults and being
explained what was going on and i
thought that was great right and i think
as you can see in this leadership
contest i'm happy to subject myself to
all the scrutiny there is i'm you know
i'll happily have anyone interview me as
you've seen in this leadership contest
because i think that's how you build
trust right and one of the things we
need to do is rebuild trust back into
government and that comes from being
transparent with the country from being
honest about what we're doing and data
is a big part of it but i would say that
you mentioned all those things you're
right
data is helpful because it will help us
figure out where the problems are but
what you also need is courage you need
you need to be radical you need to be
bold if we're going to reform public
services like the nhs we can have all
the data in the world but if we're not
going to actually confront some of the
conventions we're not going to do things
differently like i want to tackle this
issue of missed hospital appointments
because it is actually costing us all a
fortune and depriving people of care
right if we're not going to do those
things with the data there's no point
because that's what i want to do i want
to reform public services with the data
i want to make them more efficient for
all of you because that's how we're
going to cut all your taxes and that's
the plan it's reform public services so
that we can cut your taxes that's a
conservative way to do the governing
that we want to see
[Applause]
hey rishi um
so
bitcoin has been around for 13 years and
uh but it and other crypto assets are
still a rapidly growing industry that
can create jobs and extensive prosperity
to our country
so what will you do to allow the uk to
become a world leader in the bitcoin and
crypto industry thank you
did jimmy did jimmy set you up to ask
that question right
look look i mean you heard me talk about
my experience in california i'm a deep
believer that we should embrace
technology and innovation as a way to
improve all our lives and make things
better make things cheaper make things
faster and as chancellor i you know i
set out actually a really positive
vision for how we can get the regulation
right to support the innovation in
cryptocurrency not just bitcoin
distributed ledger technology the
blockchain that underlies it uh so that
we can reap the benefits and actually
we've got it right and the industry was
incredibly excited about my proposals
which were better than those in the u.s
better than those in europe and as we've
always done in this country we do things
better than those competitors because we
know how to regulate flexibly not burden
people with red tape because the
innovation is going to make everyone's
lives better and it's not just about how
many bitcoins you can buy it's about how
we can change supply chains to make
things cheaper help make border and
customs processes more efficient how we
can actually solve the appointments
issue in the nhs using that technology
how we can make the cheaper and easier
for you all to bank that's the real
benefit of all those things and i want
the uk to be the home of that innovation
and i put us on a path to deliver it as
chancellor and as prime minister you
better believe i want to see that come
to fruition
um i come from wilden nice area to live
area of outstanding natural beauty one
of the biggest problems we've got is
planning yes house builders are all over
us
the conservatives are losing council
seats right left and center to the lib
dems and the greens now we've heard from
you and from liz that you both want to
change the system of top down levels of
housing
but can we believe you because at the
moment i know wilder have been battling
away with the minister or whichever one
it is this week
trying trying to convince them that
their methodology is wrong that the
numbers are wrong and that they know
best where housing should go in our area
and they're falling on deaf ears so how
can we trust what you've been saying to
us tonight
yeah right
[Applause]
well look sir i actually i met with your
council leader today and we talked about
this very issue and you've heard from me
what i want to do about it there
shouldn't be top-down targets imposed on
places like wilden that don't take into
account the very particular local
circumstances particularly as you guys
have got about i think 80 or 85 percent
of the land is an aonb it's an area of
outstanding national beauty and the
planning inspector needs to be told that
that needs to be taken into account when
you're deciding how you want to build
your houses no one can tell you what to
do without realizing that that is
something that needs to be protected and
under my leadership and the plans i want
to put in place it will be protected
because i want to protect your green
spaces and trust you to get on with the
job of delivering houses for your
community in the way that you think the
best right but the other thing we need
to do to help you is tackle this issue
of build out because you have done a
great job in wielding council of
actually making sure that we can have
the right housing in the right places
because we all want people to enjoy that
feeling that many of us had of getting
the keys to our first home it's very
special
and you guys are doing a great job of
that but you know who's letting us down
the developers
right because yeah because you you and
wilden in particular have actually
approved homes but they're not being
built the developers are sitting on the
land and i think that's wrong and we
need to stop it and we need to give you
the powers to charge them or buy the
land back or not give them any more
planning permissions until they've built
them out those are the plans that i
outlined today and they're going to help
you
[Applause]
elected at 20 unseating a lib dem by 15
votes last year
my residents in westway ward have come
to me with concerns about their social
housing that is run by the residents
association lib dem administration at
sandridge district council
what legislation are you going to put
into place as prime minister to ensure
that local councils and housing
associations
uh have the best
quality social housing
right taylor well first of all enormous
congratulations to you that's cracking
result well done uh look i don't have a
immediate answer for you i i thought we
were already in the process of making
sure that there were standards that were
put in place or to make sure that people
have high quality homes it was called
the decent home standard and we were in
the process of implementing it because
you're right people deserve to have
homes that are fit for habitation and
when that's not happening the people
doing that should be held to account
particularly because they're using
government funds to build those homes so
it's simply unacceptable we should not
have tolerance for it and i'm happy to
take it away with you and figure out
what we need to do to make it right
simple as that
[Applause]
i'm just conscious i'm not picking
anyone from behind me because it's
really difficult to sort of spin around
so let's have that lady let's have that
lady there thank you very much and rishi
you seem like a lovely chap
and you've talked about trust a lot
which is great
but we all know that sometimes people
don't do what you want them to do and
you have to be tough and hold people to
account how can you reassure us that you
will be tough
when you need to be when people aren't
performing yeah well look that's a it's
a great question right and the simple
simple answer is look i i had to do it
in my business career right everyone's
got a lot of commentary on you know
where i am today and all the things that
i'm fortunate to enjoy i didn't get
there by being easy on people i got
there by being tough right if you want
to succeed in business you need to be
able to do that and that's what i've
done but i've also demonstrated that in
politics right and dom talked about it
when it came to the brexit decision a
lot of pressure was put on me to do
something i didn't want to do
and even though that was going to be
difficult for me i wanted to stick with
my principles i toughed it out because i
backed what i believe i backed britain
and i backed brexit when it came to
omicron last christmas i was actually in
california on a business trip trying to
make sure that we can get all the
innovation that we need here in the uk
and it was clear that this country was
about to sleep walk into another
lockdown because that's what the
establishment wanted
that was the default lever that they
always pulled and i was convinced it was
wrong for our country so i came back
here i didn't see my family over the
christmas holidays because every day i
sat here and made sure that i fought
against that even though that was
difficult because at some points it was
me and one other person against an
entire room but i wanted to fight for
what was right for this country
hi
richie
um given the
the current morgan crisis and the
government's rwanda policy
as a sovereign nation we can
but more importantly should we leave the
european court of human rights yeah
well
so we may have to and no option should
be off the table so for those who are
interested in this topic on my website
there's a detailed 10-point plan for how
i want to tackle this issue there's a
video i'll give you two things that we
need to do out of that plan right now
one is we need to move away from the
echr definition of asylum because it's
very broad it's being exploited by lefty
lawyers it means it's very difficult for
us to send people back so i want to move
to a different standard at different
international standards that's narrower
and tighter and that will help us
execute the policy a second thing we
need to do is join up our foreign policy
at the moment we're in this slightly odd
situation where we'll talk to a country
about a trade deal we might give them
we'll go even further and talk to them
about the aid that we're going to give
them but at the same time we don't tell
them they have to take back their failed
asylum seekers right that's clearly
bonkers right so we need to be tougher
on things like that so there's a range
of other things in my plan to grip the
situation dominic who you heard from
earlier has got a new british bill of
rights it's also going to help i want to
see if all those things work but if they
don't then no option will be off the
table because we have to make the rwanda
policy work and i will do whatever it
takes to make it work because we must
have control of our borders
good evening
my question to you rishi is
about inflation i'd like to know how you
intend
to get inflation under control
given
that it's been fueled by global supply
chain issues soaring global energy costs
and the war in the ukraine
well this is the most important question
that confronts our country at the moment
the most important one man you all heard
what the bank of england said
and as i said the other night
the warning lights on our economy are
flashing red
and the root cause of that is inflation
and yes it's primarily driven by
international causes but not exclusively
and increasingly is becoming domestic so
the first thing we need to do if we're
going to grip this is not make the
situation worse and put fuel on the fire
and repeat the mistakes of the past and
as you heard from nigel lawson margaret
patch's chancellor about those just the
other day i believe that pumping 40 50
billion pounds i can't keep up of
borrowed money into an economy that's
already seeing an inflation spiral is
enormously risky it is taking a big
gamble with your savings your pensions
and your mortgage rates and that is not
a gamble that i'm prepared to take the
first thing we need to do is not make
the situation worse the second thing we
need to do is to support people through
the autumn and the winter the moments
who most need our help with the cost of
living which of course will do and then
longer term how do we get inflation down
we increase the supply of things right
that's reasonably easy for us to grasp
where do we have inflation we have in
our labor market which is why we need to
get much tougher on welfare because at
the moment there are more people on
unemployment benefit than there are job
vacancies in the economy that's not
right we need to be conservative about
that we need to reform welfare to get
those people into work and ease some of
those bottlenecks we need more homegrown
food as i talk to me about we need more
homegrown energy whether it's offshore
wind or new nuclear reactors that are
going to power our homes and we need to
get our businesses investing and that's
why the tax cuts that i talked about are
focused on those businesses that are
actually expanding production expanding
capacity investing and growing because
if we get them to do that to get through
these bottlenecks and increase supply
that's how we'll get inflation down so
it's not just a problem this winter and
that's it because i don't want it to be
a problem next winter and beyond so
that's my plan to grip it but i tell you
the most important thing is not to
repeat the mistakes of the past and put
fuel on the fire of a problem which
we're already suffering that's not going
to help any of you in this room it's not
going to help our country and it is
going to mean that we lose the next
election
[Applause]
we all got a sheet of paper identifying
the policies that both you and liz trust
put forward i was very disappointed and
i know a lot of young people in
particular will have been very
disappointed there was absolutely no
coverage of climate change or
environmental problems
that is not a secondary problem it's a
priority that we invest and we influence
the whole world to invest in recovering
there what will you do about it yes well
look
i have two young girls
so i have two i have two little girls
and for the last couple of years while
i've had this you know important job
they are not remotely interested in it
for the most part and they the one thing
they asked me about is daddy what are
you doing about the environment right
what are you doing about climate change
that's all they really are interested in
right so i don't want to let them down
first and foremost and in the same way
you've heard me talk passionately about
the public finances the borrowing and
the debt that we leave to our kids and
our grandkids i'm equally passionate
about the environment that we leave them
because we're conservatives
we work hard to build a better future
and leave something for our kids that's
a very conservative instinct and it goes
for the environment as it does for
anything else but look yeah i do believe
in our net zero target i want us to get
there in a measured way because there is
no point in us racing there harder and
faster than any other country because
that will just both impoverish us and
lose people's support on the journey and
i don't want that right so we need to do
it in a measured way and the way we're
going to solve that problem is not by
getting people to give up all the things
they love it's not about putting up all
their bills it's about innovation
it's about what i talked about it's
about building that innovation economy
of the future where our scientists our
researchers our entrepreneurial
companies are creating the solutions to
the problem whether it's a new
generation of small modular reactors
that we can not only use here but we can
export around the world whether it's
energy storage whether it's more better
use of our environmental agricultural
land that's exactly what we're already
doing but it's not just about government
investment right that's not the
conservative answer to this it's not
about how much money can the government
throw at this problem it's about
unlocking the creativity ingenuity
entrepreneurship of the private sector
that's where conservatives that's what
we believe
right
i asked you in january for your advice
on having two daughters and you said be
very kind to your parents is the first
thing and that is
absolutely true and they're there in the
audience i don't know who's maybe
sitting tonight
thank you
i just wanted to um say like it's
obviously been a tough leadership
contest lots of blue on blue you've
spent a lot of time with your opponent
in the last couple of weeks and i gotta
spend another month as well traveling
the country together what do you most
admire in what she's trying to do
i mean i think what liz is great at is
explaining conservative values right i
mean she's great at having being having
high conviction and conservative values
and being unashamed about them as i am
right that's something that we both
passionately believe i think the other
thing about liz as you i'm sure saw this
evening as you'll see from both of us
over the next four weeks is look we all
know in this room and liz and i know who
the real opponent is here it's not me
it's not liz it's not any of the other
people that were standing in this
leadership contest right we know who it
is and in a few weeks time we're all one
family here right we're all one team
we're on the same team we're in the same
family we're going to come together
we're going to serve the british people
build the better britain and then we're
going to take the fight to kierstarma
and whether that's liz or me i know that
she cares equally about that as i do as
all of you in this room do because if we
don't do that all the things that we're
discussing all the values that we hold
here
it's all for naught if we can't win that
next election that's what she's focused
on that's what i'm focused on and i know
it's what all of you are focused on too
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
rishi was clearly listening because he
said you didn't ask me about my favorite
podcast and he said his just then it's
faster please so make sure you check
that out as well thank you all for
coming this evening it's been brilliant
to have you all here and as rishi says
let's focus the next election on beating
kierstarma thank you very much
[Applause]